samurai champloo is about a group
consisting of Mugen Fuu engine and
follows their merry adventures to find
the samurai who smells of sunflowers and
in the end they find him the end all
right all right I was just kidding
samurai Champloo the second series
directed by shin xuan Tanabe the bloke
behind that little knowing anime called
Cowboy Bebop
and it's also inherently his second
attempt at creating a hip
action-oriented showdown in the star to
appeal to Western audiences wait am I on
sorry it's not samurai champloo it's Tom
that's better anyways oh my god doesn't
have much of a plot since I just
basically summed it up in the first
census of this review but the series is
more episodic where each episode
contains a story of its own with the
show being more about the journey than
the actual destination itself the three
main characters include Mugen probably
the most badass samurai in the history
of anime since at the end of the day the
matter who you are if you're going up
against the breakdancing samurai voiced
by Steve bloom in the context of
badassery you're going to [ __ ] lose
and then there's food who is officially
one of the dollar's anime characters in
the world so instead of challenging
myself to think up a joke here's a
monkey on a pushbike
Anjan who's an even duller anime
character than foo so you know what is
the same monkey with a different song on
top okay okay okay fine I'll do this
review properly Ginny is your generic
emotionless Tamara who has less
personality than a stone statue of a
dreary gardenia only Reeves and Fuu is
well actually there isn't a lot I could
say about food because I couldn't for
the life of me figure out what her
purpose was what she dare to be helpful
[ __ ] no well she seems to do was wine
trip over a lot I get kidnapped was she
there for the found service I don't
think so because a part of that famous
Diggle in the first episode there wasn't
a lot of fanservice in the series was
she there to move the plot along ha ha
ah no now I don't know we mention
soundtracks in my reviews I think the
one in Tamil deserves a mention because
the anime uses hip-hop as its main theme
for the soundtrack and while I was
skeptical at first the music fits
surprisingly well considering I'm not a
huge fan of hip-hop myself animation
also gets a special mention since this
is one of the best animated shows I've
seen there's done in a sort of cinematic
style with the backgrounds moving in
real time and it does have those flying
lines in the background are the
characters that magically jump to
hyperspace every time they go for an
attack this gave the anime some of the
coolest sword fights I've seen whether
it be Jin's calm and composed way of
swinging the sword or mood is crazy
unorthodox fighting Staller that black
girl tech and who break dancers that I
could already used to be my old friends
by just randomly mashing buttons and
he'd always complain because he thought
you can that character is cheating and I
should use a proper character but I
thought it was just a sore loser and
well yeah who's laughing now Dean sorry
got a bit off-topic there so anyway with
all this great animation and soundtrack
but let's be honest a pretty pants
storyline something else needs to be
present to make the show worth watching
let me introduce y'all to the rule of
cool rule of cause when a series like
our boy bebop can be excused for not
having much of a plot and mineral
character development because it's so
[ __ ] bad-ass rule of cause when the
over-the-top fighting gear on the gong
could get so stupid that buddy and they
could be throwing dildo shaped quasars
at each other and you'd still be sitting
there cleaning off the gum stains in
your pants because those fights made out
sheer awesomeness
see if a series is deemed cool enough
you're willing to forgive it for its
flaws that would otherwise apply the
anime to the dark pits of hell black
lagoon does this Black Canary does is
and Shapley does--is but not perfectly
see a show like summer on earth has the
episodic nature needs live off the rule
of cool to survive it does this well to
an extent but suddenly not as well as
the Grandmaster Daddy of more Cowboy
Bebop
it just seems sometimes the show tried
to be too hard to be different and cool
I just made
consistent with some episodes being
totally awesome while other episodes
being just plain average the
action-oriented episodes are all pretty
much badass my scale of once badass but
economy episodes were a bit hit and miss
with episodes like the zombie one in the
graffiti when being medical while
episodes like the one where Mugen takes
on a whole underground mafia for a
chance of getting laid being absolutely
hilarious alright let's get down to
business here I guess you could sum up
most floors of Champloo in five words I
want to be like Bebop and six words shut
up nobody was counting anyway in my
opinion the character dynamics just went
as strong as they were in Bebop and he
can try to convince me all you want
about how shampoos different than bebop
but there are so many similarities
between the two that they might as well
be siblings oh my god isn't the perfect
anime and it does drag on sometimes but
despite flaws I would recommend that you
watch anyway if not for the great
animation in some of the best action
I've seen what's your for the experience
because let's be honest whales will
you'll be able to see beatboxing samurai
or breakdancing swordsman or than always
pretty obvious that wantanabe tried to
make the show appeal to the Western
audience like he did with bebop though
any and all he really needed to do to
make the show fit in with Western
culture was include a few dick jokes now
and then I give this an me an 8 out of
10
we
oh my god
member